it's podcast time podcast I'm Johnny and
you serve podcast time some of the
questions we get and we're just like
sorry guys it's also our first pandemic
so wait wait you do this - we're just
trying our best as well I'm just leave
us alone I just wanted to say something
I saw her Instagram that I thought was
fantastic
which was a very Georgia man saying like
yeah the other day I took me Ben out
right I got a [ __ ] round of applause
my upstairs neighbor has taken up the
drums and is having a lot more sex like
it is directly above my bedroom and it's
at all times of the day so I think
there's a dog peeing outside no it's not
it's fine fine but that's the choice
that I've made by living here in front
of the window where I can spot people
peeing outside masks so
ladies and gentlemen welcome back its
podcast time podcast I'm Johnny and you
save podcast time welcome back gentlemen
very good to see you good morning
morning the Skype can it can everybody
see everybody yeah at once yeah so if
when you're speaking if I go yes I can
see you making embarrassing reactions to
what I say yeah so yeah for anyone
that's listening like the reason
Johnny's asked that's because the
previous episode we were using a
different bit of software where if
someone was talking the other person
could be like and it was fine because
you couldn't see them yeah whereas now
we're all on view well he says you serve
and Johnny A+ a fact that they can't be
snide behind my back while we're doing
the podcast I'll make funny faces
[Music]
so what date what day is it
Saturday April 4th we're recording this
I think this will go out in just a
couple of days so um yeah we just
thought we do catch-up episode obviously
we I mean this is the first time I've
got to see either of you two since the
last one since ketchup which is kind of
funny like since isolation hacks we
haven't seen each other and now we get
to see each other again it's like a
podcast yeah yeah it's also odd that all
of our lifestyles have barely changed
like I mean Chris go to the club less
but me and Johnny exactly the same
Christa CrossFit just somewhere else
Sundays at the botanist and Wednesday
night at the dog inherit that's what you
mean is long it's when you do when you
do Riverside at Blanc that's Monday's
Riverside at Blanc yeah that's it for
those for those who don't know what we
run about I've been friends with Yusef
for nearly 10 years now and in that
entire time he's never once got my
portfolio of events correct like he just
keeps her so it's a it's a Wednesday so
you must be at work tonight right I'm I
use if I've never run a Wed and stay my
entire career the drinks event that you
run at the social club in Leeds that you
do it started
isn't it 8 a.m. for 8:30 you get formal
dress
yeah that's yes or less time WR right
like I mean what's changed in your life
blob because you just moved her I wanted
to bring this affects you first thing I
want to bring up how antifragile is
having a dog and a garden during
lockdown yeah it's pretty good I mean I
still go for walks so like so what's
changed I suppose that the main change
and probably the yeah the main changes I
would normally work somewhere else like
a few days in the week in the morning so
I'd go to a coffee shop or something
like that I remember that last visit I
had to a coffee shop actually well like
there was led you to choose it was
losing cost Koster in town it was
average to be honest but really good
Wi-Fi I feel like I could write a like a
50 page guide on like how to select your
coffee shop but anyway so you walk in
and everyone's like you know sort of
this was unlike that there was talk of
lockdown talk of quarantine signs
everywhere saying we will not accept
cash and that I nearly said to the
person taking my order like why is that
not just always the case maybe four
majorly iteration wouldn't be quite as
bad if people didn't like hand each
other bits of paper but you go to the
till your hand there's been like give
your role played with cocaine and sweat
receipt which just pumps you're not that
risk is like viral you catch a virus or
estrogen yeah yeah you get some kind of
like long-term hormonal problem so tell
me what promoting the ODE protes
what they called ot --nz when a guy like
ran up to me to give me a no team bar in
corridor tell me what has what has
changed then apart from coffee shop
visits blob searches i suppose like i
would you know in the evening becker and
i would sometimes have plans like
obviously we would be doing these on a
sofa
your house like this would be happening
on an evening for like three hours loads
of bright lights but that doesn't happen
anymore but like not not much really and
I feel like a bit of a [ __ ] saying that
who you mate but like I suppose I feel
like so - two really interesting things
one is I I'm normally pretty bad for
like worrying about my health like if I
think I've got something wrong with me
like it consumes my thoughts for weeks
and I always assume the worst surfers
like I have something tiny wrong with me
I assume it's horrendous but at the
moment like I just I'm not that worried
about this but a lot of people I know
are a lot more worried than they ever
have been and a lot of people are really
struggling with being in the house and
the sort of the isolation side of it but
I think the way it feels is like I've
been dealing with sort of those worries
for like years so now it's just like
well everyone else is the gundermen yeah
it's like I think just I've just had
practice in both of the concern both of
the struggle points which is like
worrying about your health being at home
on your own dealing with work just by
yourself in front of a laptop so a video
must form the guilt or whatever is that
you're referring to there of feeling a
bit like a [ __ ] is something I've been
dealing with as well it's I don't know
whether it's like a survivor a survivor
guilt or whatever it might be but the
fact that it doesn't feel painful to me
to live the life that I've always lived
or have done in the last few years like
very little for me has changed did a
dimple or my Instagram asking all I
could ask people for questions and
there's definitely some people out there
that are struggling a lot more I mean
some people who message saying that they
live on their own this one girl said me
and my partner are going through a
really difficult time at the moment and
were self isolating in different houses
so that imagine trying to negotiate a
relationship like a bad relationship
when you're both locked down another
person said I'm really extroverted I get
super depressed when I'm on my own and
I'm there's me living life like no
longer no longer having my sleeper
routine and messed up like don't get me
wrong I miss all my mates I miss getting
to see you guys I miss going to work I
miss actually being at work and seeing
the nightclubs at
you know getting that buzz and stuff but
this part of me that just the novelty of
doing more of stuff that I like to do is
cool and it'll wear off but there's a
guilt there's like a I don't know I just
feel like um I shouldn't be this the it
should be harder I should be suffering
more for being at home and then there's
the complete opposite end of the scale
which is dr. scone this is a really
interesting point that not only the
three of us are experiencing Bates
it's totally Universal and that is the
lifestyle choices that you've made have
consequences like as obvious as that
sounds like you pay your money you take
your choice and whatever whatever way
that you set up your life it has
advantages in some circumstances and
disadvantages and others so I think
there's a dog peeing outside no it's not
it's fine fine but that's the choice
that I've made by living here in front
of the window where I can spot people
peeing outside park so this is this is
my point that you guys have you've set
up your life in such a way that during
normal non pandemic times you have
insecurities of income you have lower
scope for social life than than others
because of the hours that you do or the
people that you live with you know
that's that's a choice that you've made
and you have to be with them through
thick and thin and so what the advantage
might be in one circumstance could be a
disadvantage in the other and vice versa
so your friend who's extroverted and
needs human company the way they serve
their life normally means they they reap
the advantages of that but then when
they're in lockdown it's a bad thing
vice-versa for us like equally the job
of the junior doctor can be a bit
rubbish at times but what I have got is
the job security during a pandemic that
someone who works in graphic design
doesn't have and so I don't see any of
these things as an advantage or
disadvantage they're just the
consequence of the decision that we've
all made
and so I don't think you should feel
guilty about it because they will
certainly be a time where you experience
the the blunt end of it as well yeah for
sure
ad ISM there was part of me at the very
beginning I wonder whether you felt this
is well Johnny I was taking far too much
pleasure in other people's struggling to
generate their own meaning and their own
motivation so I was seeing a lot of
people saying ah it's really hard
working from home and I'm really not got
a routine and I just keep eating because
I'm constantly in the house and all
isn't it difficult when you're in your
bedroom working as opposed to in you and
I was like yeah you [ __ ]
how do you think it's been for me for
the last 10 years like welcome to my
world
nikki is just feeling vindicated just
like I should you know like it's taken a
it took a week for me to work through
that and for me to fully let go and be
like Don cathartic ly take pleasure in
the fact that other people have entered
your nightmare yeah something I keep
seeing people like entrepreneurs I
follow posting is the idea that ye fall
you always fall to the level of your
training and I think the thing that I
have definitely witnessed a few sort of
like people on my in my social circle
kind of spin out of control a little bit
with this happening and I think if
you're but there's also people who just
continued as normal so I do think it's
as you so says like the choices you make
of sort of building a building routines
and your life building habits in your
life and holding on trying to hold on to
those if the rest of your life kind of
falls out falls away around you you can
you've still got those those aspects of
consistency and you're dead and I said
look for people because for a lot of a
lot of people training and exercise and
that is normally a fairly consistent
healthy habit they do but there's still
loads of other things that you can like
as we discussed last time like continue
you're saying what you do in the morning
continue what you do in the evening try
and keep that structure and then the
frustration that comes with it and
feeling like you're just sort of
slipping into this putrid mess you know
progressively over the over the weeks
like that that's
as bad so this is there like one month's
crisis is the other man's opportunity
like the three things that you've
mentioned they're like baby you've got
you normally operate in a routine
someone would during normal time some
people are made not so restrictive like
you can't do the things it's like well
yes but that's a double-edged sword
because now when there is nothing else
to do you have the momentum of the
routine and you know you and
productivity hasn't changed you've got a
dog which most of the time can be a
bollock but during a pandemic demand for
dogs has gone up so much like all the
dog adoption centers of completely is
this against that like yeah like people
are just desperately looking for you
know the the home gym like yes that's a
poor leichter syrup and it's expensive
to get in it and it's cold and but now
like you're the winner with with a home
gym he's just described in your honor
thing what looking like he's training is
unaffected like if you're the dealer are
you sir
just did a heavy Burke on style deadlift
session the other days like how many
people can say that now yeah that is the
thing is even even when you do the maths
like I don't think a home gym makes
financial sense like when you added up
like what it costs to sort of get what
you need to Train normally you wouldn't
I think it takes like ten years to
recoup it but you have the you have the
ability to sort of control this little
environment that you can manage no one's
ever using your barbell but no-one's
ever like wants to squat what every fit
Pro on Instagram is doing which is jump
squats and their mum's conservatory and
like doing presses with the can of beans
it's my weight
have you seen the guy that all these
people doing glute thrusts in in their
living room that's like saying I'll get
big biceps by doing that it's like most
is go and watch Eric Helms training on
Instagram because he's just doing it in
a car park so he's got like a basic
barbell he's got like a barbell
unlike other basic kit and he's just
gone to like it must be the part the
carpark of like his flat or something
what sorry
he's American he lives in New Zealand so
he's at least I think so okay he's
managing to put together like some
pretty like sessions that I think I'd
enjoy doing but it's just the location I
just I love that he's like no I'm still
gonna have an area where I train and it
just so happens that that area is gonna
be a public carpark man but he's like
away from everything and it's brilliant
so so funny watch I've I want to start a
movement which is hashtag [ __ ] lifting
Club and it includes all of the people
at the moment like me so I had my
doormats down on my decking the other
day to protect them from the dumbbells
that I was putting down and Alfie
Armstrong and suni Webster I know at the
moment are both using wheelie bins as
squat racks so they're squatting in and
out of the sunís got lifting blocks so
that he can do like jerks from blocks
but he's just it's just too wheelie bins
apparently the wheelie bin I wouldn't
trust he been being that strong Alfie's
got 100 kilos on to wheelie bins and
they look pretty they look pretty legit
just on the lid on the lid yeah it's
distributed though isn't it 50 kilos on
each one that's all I suppose this would
be excited to do it if you were able to
shave the handle off get rid like snap
the handle off it turn it upside down so
that you've got the base
I bet the base is strong as [ __ ] you got
that no anyway [ __ ] lifting club if
you've got any if you are doing some
[ __ ] lifting I want to find out about
it so give me a message and let me know
what you so I'm Seth like you are as
frontline you're the vanguard against
this current situation tell us tell us
what it's like one literally be the
frontline it's it's quite nice to see
the like the the applause the other day
out in the in the streets like that was
quite sweet quite heartwarming I was
like I felt DJ as a health worker do you
feel that in it there's the two two
parts to it so the the applause like
that was that was
nice it's nice to hear that the public
appreciated I ironically I only realized
what it was about
in retrospect because I was between
night shifts and I was just like Oh
annoyed at being woken up by all these
workers clapping outside yeah like you
you're actually too busy to remote like
be able to take notice of it but on the
other hand it's really nice to see that
people actually do have some level of
compassion at least where we are
I'm sure there's like dicks and in
London though whatever they're just
still ignoring the whole isolation thing
but it's always in London isn't it yeah
but but it's nice that everyone's
actually been like you know what yes
this is an illness that probably won't
kill me
but for the sake of Grandma for the sake
of the NHS the old the older populations
all of this we're gonna pile together
and actually do something proper about
this and so seeing people observe a
isolation quite strictly is quite nice
quite heartwarming to see and it's not
something I'd expected and it seems like
the UK we did flatten the curve enough
for us not to have this absolute mad
spike that the likes of Italy are seeing
you know when we're not we're not having
to just like you know put people on
ventilators in the carpark and that kind
of thing so from our perspective it's
lovely the other perspective like we a
lot of company we got like five percent
off Pizza Express or whatever and you
like I could prefer a pay rise rather
than just like a 10% off subway the
coaster in the hospital started offering
free coffees for staff do you know how
long it lasted for 24 hours oh yeah why
because then they all I got pounded I
guess so or just they were like hey cuz
I but whereas my perspective is like
cost it if they know they're going under
they should just be like let's just go
out with a bang let's go out doing
something like we're making a massive
loss anyway let's just give NHS staff a
free drink in the name
at least looks good for PR on the way
out um I want to just sort of interject
that I think
know that it must suck right now and if
there's NHS staff listening I apologize
for how poorly you're being treated and
paid at the moment but thank you for
your service how does the annoying part
because like with being the the hours
and the nights and everything they're
only gonna increase we're putting
yourself at a very high risk of
additional viral load plus combination
of being run down between nights like
being on for you master armed to become
infected and then if you become infected
that further strains the other health
care workers that are beside mana is
like yeah it's literally like someone
created in a virtual world how how would
you make the health care services
vulnerable and as on a knife-edge as
possible but and when we reintegrate
which you inevitably it's gonna happen
at some point [ __ ] better do
hopefully I know for a fact month at NHS
workers are going to get so I strongly
predict free gym memberships for NHS
workers will be doing probably free
entry into all of our club nights with
an NHS thing for the next year something
like that I imagine that a lot of
businesses will try to repay NHS workers
when they can you know it's not our job
to say what the NHS should pay you
although probably would be nice to be
more we can't control that but as a
small business owner I imagine that you
know if you've got a cafe 19 or one in
Jesmond or something like that and
you've got an NHS thing I wouldn't
surprise me if they say you've got fifty
percent off your food or you get free
coffee or sounds lovely I think for the
last few weeks all the globe all that
you know health care stuff across the
world have been crying for is that can
we just have a mask that fits properly
that can we just have the audible
equipment that I own a garlic bread I
want I want my I want the proper kit
please yeah yeah yeah I want to not be
wearing a sock over my face just before
they go further down this I just wanted
to say something I saw her Instagram
that I thought was fantastic which was a
very Geordie man saying like yeah the
other day I took me Ben out right and I
got a [ __ ] round of applause
I think the thing that like the
Silverlight have all this stuff is
there's a few people a few very dry very
sarcastic people on social media who
just spot these opportunities have you
seen the one of the guy who is like I
was out in Tesco today and there wasn't
much food available on the shelves and I
went to this this couple and that
trolley was absolutely full of stuff and
I I say excuse me would you mind awfully
sparing a couple of items for and it was
great and they gave me some hummus
and son and he's holding a gun
[Laughter]
absolutely lovely the other thing I feel
so smug about is having the bomb gun the
shot buffer bless you man it's you've
you've got scaleable toilet paper oh my
god it's incredible so you have a I
think can you describe briefly briefly
describe what it is you've got in your
bathroom for people that didn't listen
to that life except assess wall-mounted
high pressure hose that you can spray at
your bum not in your bum at your bum to
reduce the requirement for toilet roll
high-pressure hose makes some more
rudimentary than it is it's actually
it's a real nice chrome with a pressure
what what's happened Johnny have you had
something no no I've just remembered
something it's related to that about wim
HOF in the sauna photo op yes have you
seen a photo of wim Hof's bellybutton
no no right so I'm doing his 10 week
course at the moment all right which
involved yes and you stand out who you
you know how I fix my scoliosis hours of
yoga I think 72 hours of holotropic
breathing per day I mean that would be
you know reduce if did that yelled ohio
man ladies on for three hours what I
mean what a listening experience this
must be solid well no but if people with
all of this has been all of
is referenced in previous episodes and
if you don't know what if you don't know
I use have held a German lady's hand if
you don't know why Johnny had an
out-of-body experience if you don't know
who wim hof is just go back go back
listen to the whole catalogue and you'll
know what we run about well it says
anyway so I was what I was watching this
video I was like he's got a really weird
band button I'm gonna find out why so I
googled why does wim hof have a weird
bellybutton and someone's written a
really long answer I don't know whether
this is true but the guy claimed to be
like involved in writing his book but he
didn't go too much into this story
because when you hear ye hear ye it's
like oh my god that's mental so
apparently what happened fountain right
where women swims in and he gives
himself an enema on the fountain and he
was gonna go do it again but the time
that he did it again they turned the
pressure up on the jet and so it like
cut through his whatever bits and he
needed like major surgery and stuff so
Yusef as a health professional can you
debunk or confirm whether or not wim HOF
has an outie now because he filled his
abdomen up with more than a problem it's
more than a little Willy something's
going on here no just like a little
Willy it just doesn't look normal
doesn't it normal but apparently it's
because I mean take that with a pinch of
salt like I don't know whether that's
true or not that's just what I read from
one person but if someone's made that up
like what a small most fair enough fair
enough - be like post-surgical hernia
that he's that he's developed from
promise it rather than like the enema I
know I don't think the water blew out
his bellybutton
I think it is from the surgery but I'm
talking about personal protective
equipment have you seen the rogue have
started producing those clear face masks
so that that's another fantastic thing
that I'm seeing with people pulling
together the rogue rolls-royce general
motors making shoes lemurs have stopped
making shoes to make things we'll still
be buying shoes because everyone what
suddenly
like sorry another tangent but something
I find hilarious is as soon as you tell
people not to do something like how many
people do you see jogging now that
you've never seen jogging before mmm
that well they didn't they should say
that counting macros increases the risk
of catching 19 catching macros are doing
a progressively overloaded training
program three four days a week has been
found to increase the risk so shuttle
out weights no what you need is Boris to
come out and say that you're not allowed
to do it okay so today I really need to
warn you against progressive overload
sets of between six and ten reps should
absolutely not and if your friends ask
you to go and do reps between six and
ten you should say [ __ ] off the picture
of Boris jogging I try and set the
example for and he's it looks like a man
is like taking the idea of jogging and
thought I'm gonna implement this he's
wearing like a fleece and like khaki
shorts and just like Boris seen doing
his daily exercise of the day any like
Jesus you know you you know you wake up
in the morning and there's a moment what
I like you forget what you want to do
today or like you forget what you're
wearing right yesterday and that's for
that like window and you're like [ __ ]
you I've got I've got that one like that
just must be every day for him now 30
seconds him and isn't 3 she reaches both
are also infected now as well right I
don't know I think so I think that's why
he's not doing the briefings but him and
Boris it's like imagine the fact that
not only if you got to try and run the
country but you've now got to try and do
it from the [ __ ] for me a house hmm
remotely yeah that there was there was a
few people kicking off on Twitter when
they were like how come Boris gets a
test for coronavirus and I don't get
you know Karen I saw I saw one I saw one
that accused Sharon and it was like why
did Boris get a test and I didn't and
someone had put it in a tweet and said
because he runs the country Sharon and
you asked for the doctor's phone number
on Facebook that was it yeah Karen
listening we don't mean you we mean your
mum the picture of like the icon
remember who she is some kind of like
public figure and just got a I want to
speak to the manager haircut when she
tweeted Americans need to know when this
is gonna end for all small businesses
and and so on responded being like so
what you're saying is you want to speak
to the manager of coronavirus yeah so a
good man M someone one man has been
commenting on every single ad we are
running at the moment I keep Smith
follically running it his way through
every variation which is quite a task
it's taking quite a while and every
everything just says does your does your
free thing that you're giving away take
into account covet 19 and the effect on
the economy it's a well I know not
really mate but like what's your
alternative like how would you shouldn't
or wouldn't use anything or do anything
I mean it's not you can go do you
propose that you're supposed to change
it anyway like what what would you do
that would be different like some of the
questions we get and we're just like
sorry guys it's also our first pandemic
so wait wait you do this - we're just
trying our best as well I'm just leave
us alone trying to D me Joanna D me job
em in I want to briefly segue here PT's
any fitness pearl that's listening
obviously now is the perfect time for
you to actually learn how to run a
business online propane business coms
oh god Chris no no no no no which one is
it propane fitness comm forward-slash
modern wisdom that's it propane
fitness.com phones much modern wisdom
and you will get a free is it still the
seven step thing the seventh step PDF or
have you changed it it's yes so it's
just the like the
seven steps you would need to start a
really highly systematized function
online business so late that's a big
deal just this seven set and it's just
free as well so go and sign up man
honestly like it is good we got some
really good feedback from modern wisdom
listeners about it it's amazing man I am
I got a bunch of messages about the how
to become an online coach thing again if
you haven't heard that that's
unbelievable
in fact just gotta listen to that listen
to that and if you don't like the sound
of being an online coach don't do it but
he's brilliant everyone came up watching
that like this you've had to put up an
honor up to his face
big smile there is there is this weird I
got asked yesterday by I think someone
who found was too modern with some
actually but he was saying surely it's
never gonna work because everyone's
trying to be an online coach and like
like everyone's using a live video
everyone's doing a story just so you
know I'm not being funny right I'm not
I'm not me I'm honestly I'm not being
funny but I have the facts it's all
gonna work oh my god sorry I need to I
need to interject here have you seen
have you looked at the complete
torpedoing of his life that Billy Joe
Saunders the boxer has managed to do in
the last seven days
right so Youssef you might not know who
Billy Joe Saunders his British boy I
don't know okay British boxer than Billy
Joe Saunders boxer um so he was lined up
to have a huge fight absolutely massive
fight which has been rearranged in the
time of the last couple of days he rang
an airport that his friend was flying
out of to tell them that his friend had
coronavirus while he was on the plane so
his friend then got pulled off and
detained with his other buddy and Billy
just across if his mate just because he
thought he'd be funny cuz he's bored um
ah and so that's that's the first one
that's the first one right remembering
this guy's a [ __ ] professional
athlete that's leaving flight they
detained on you know sites but out on
the runway so he rings him and he's okay
he faced he FaceTime to his friend while
his friend was
in the passenger seat knowing that this
was going to happen and heard the
boo-boo
[Music]
Derek Noel's please come to the and it's
like and so that happened and then then
first off you've done that right like
awful time to do and that got that was
in the press and then he's boxing in his
garage with a punching bag and he's
saying to the punching bag so guys you
might be at home and your old lady might
be giving you a bit of stick and you
might be getting a little bit sort of
annoyed by it so you know what you want
to do yeah she's coming towards you
she's riled up yeah she's angry what you
want to do you want a pop and he throws
a punch at the bag and he goes so she's
stunned right she's going what the
[ __ ] going on oh my god and then what
you want to do you want to just turn and
pop and you finish her off and then
you've got the rest of the afternoon in
peace this video was a video and it got
leaked and now he's banned from boxing
for life that's like somebody you know
like wow well the equivalent of a free
Piz
but in someone's body it's like if
someone were 24 hours in that man's body
that right how can I just I do yeah yeah
did you post that video on a social
media site no it didn't it's in a
whatsapp group it's long it's like a
minute and a half long so I'm gonna
guess maybe just in a whatsapp group but
it's got leaked and now professional
boxing license revoked everything else
like it that's a proper one-two punch
combination of how to aneil in your own
life isn't it like those two punches
ended his and his career yeah what how
can you recover from that my car is
brand as well even even if you try and
launch like a box tutorial online
self-development events for women that
would be brilliant brilliant way to
pivot now this is a total segue someone
who's really pivoted that brand really
well I'm really impressed but I'd highly
recommend everyone go watch a couple of
his videos is Eddy halls YouTube channel
is a leaf hunt sake manis nail line
haptic I just love how he doesn't take
himself like the one with him in raw
sadly you seen that where they go
swimming in the lake
I just love how like Eddie just walks
out like in budgie smugglers is huge but
quite leave now yeah but just throws
himself into anything you know younger
than us as well he's our ace out he's in
between our all of our ages yeah he's I
think 3 1 maybe
and despite when he was at the peak of
strongman he looked like 50 yeah but
yeah you totally right man there's one
with I think either Nile or his body
that he not sit gymnast yep that was
awesome
he did one with Jamie Joe how about
bodybuilding goes to strongman that was
really fun he's sponsored by boo hoo MA
he's so trendy apart from the weight so
the way that he sounds he's so trendy
mmm that's really he's got like a proper
intro I hear League OTT someone to help
him do it yeah properly he's made a
proper girl to see bro sorry did he see
him do was it grace or Isabel at the
European Championships seriously have
you not seen this no no nothing go and
watch it go watch it as soon as we're
done I can't remember whether it's grace
or Isabel I think it must be I can't
remember so it is either 30 clean and
jerks or 30 ground to overhead snatches
for time at four at 62 kilos for men and
obviously Eddie Hall essentially just
does a like an RDL into a good morning
into a front raise like that's the
movement and he just goes ha ha I'm so
like I'm pretty certain he's got the
world record in it the same way that
what's-his-face broke the hundred meter
wide short yeah bro Marius yeah that was
Brian Brian Shaw on the do you mean
Brian Shaw on the rower yeah yeah what
was Marie I think Mary's got a new inner
he was a Polish strong man I think he
got a really good time and another
strong man started being aa was like the
the strong man that was just like peeled
all of the time like there's loads of
footage of him doing like a farmers walk
with like full like forearm vascularity
eat striations in his bicep anyone's
like what I use that but do you like
used to win win loads of events while
being like body builder conditions
constantly well
so one of the most common questions I'm
seeing posted online at the moment is
any good books podcasts Netflix series
slash movies to watch or whatever else
what have you guys been consuming I
guess you Saif must be just necessarily
normal life yeah yeah well just try
medical information v yeah so for me
I've not got a very good answer to that
I've seen half of an episode of tiger
king brilliant which line which Chris
mentioned yesterday said Youssef that's
the equivalent for you of watch watching
a back-to-back Lord of the Rings
marathon watching half an episode I'm
surprised that you got through half an
episode it is brilliant you haven't seen
that yet have you Johnny
so so I got that message from soso
backer and I try to watch it like a week
ago
got like half an hour in a bit weird
might might give up on this kept seeing
stuff on Instagram about it kept saying
to a like there's a lot of stuff about
this series like it is number one in the
UK then you sent me that message and I
was like being like Yusuf's watched half
of it like what did she say last night
we like made it through like I think
we're on the second episode and I can
get marketer slowly it sort of the
kittens and I'm like okay felt like fair
enough so yeah you know you know honest
it's you know on Facebook you can mark
yourself safe from natural disasters so
there's like tsunamis and things and
it's like Jonathan Watson has marked
himself safe from Thailand tsunami or
whatever um I saw him Facebook the other
day someone who had marked themselves
safe from that [ __ ] Carol Baskin do you
know what was what was that TV it was it
was either a single episode it was a
series where like there was like an
abduction and it ended up with like the
dad I given the bloke a hand job in a
car
[ __ ] like science festival no use of
two Netflix series repository of I'd be
so bad on like these game shows where
the like topic is movies great I've seen
three No
another one that you mean Johnny so um
okay you've not been consuming an awful
lot Seth what have you been watching or
listening to or enjoying Johnny what's
that so that's the thing I'm I'm
currently just started watching Ozark is
just in my opinion the best thing on TV
mainly because I just really like the
main character Jason Bateman's character
as an accountant he's just so he isn't
accountant but that's it's it's more
like and you'll see this from the first
series he's plunged into a very
stressful situation like he's being
pursued by a Mexican cartel because he's
involved in laundering money for them
and they start like they find out he's
been doing some naughty things well not
ruin it for people but he just remains
completely calm the entire time and he's
asleep
his wife's like panicking musics like
it's okay
well go here do this go there they
probably all be able to find us it'll
all be fine and he's just always on his
laptop looking at the high level looking
at the spreadsheet to solve a situation
I love it it's brilliant so good right
so that yeah well I you see like one
liar on BBC what's a liar yeah so it's
in the second season now I think the
first it might be on ITV actually
basically a is a surgeon who I don't
know how to say this without really
sorry he gets accused of raping someone
and then the the season unfolds the
story unfolds very good British actors
British drama Brits the guy who played
Hornblower
I only know him so like I looked him up
on IMDB yeah I looked up an intp but the
thing I remembered I could just remember
seeing an episode and I was like eight
Hornblower on TV just so you know he's
very that not The Lion King but Tiger
King yep I've got an Apple TV trial all
right I want something called the
servant by EM no chime alone so they
they're not only a and like a stick but
also a production studio as well so
they've now basically made their own
Netflix yeah and as you'd expect from
Apple like pretty much every single one
of the like Apple originals has got like
Jennifer Aniston in well you know
they've all got a bit like Hollywood at
its AG swing yeah because that it's like
what do you do when you've when you've
got a trillion dollars of cash you're
like well we'd like to make something
this like as good as Netflix Shrek and
Jennifer and well it's paid in cash I
reckon she does I don't know I think
it's probably probably us to go into a
bank account it's only it's only Apple
that could step in and be like well
we'll have a go at Netflix like John she
fancies starting Apple Apple Studios ah
well yeah no worries I will so cool so
actually cool stuff that I've consumed
recently I sent you guys the link to
that Fat Tony video didn't I the guy
that spent a million pounds on drugs
I put her in the big dicks grouping on
what sir
is it someone that you've just you all
must as well yeah
so either Mixmag uploaded a facebook
video why why would you anyway so they
uploaded it really well produced full
documentary 20 minute documentary edited
archive footage interviews with him and
his mum following him around it's just
this guy who at the age of 16 managed to
kind of spawn his way into being a DJ
and then became best friends with Boy
George
Paris Hilton like everyone every single
gave them who's that famous British
model that loves drugs female I don't
know Chris get the London look you will
do like Bradley Pitt no yeah Kate Moss
right Kate Moss fifteen-year-old Kate
Moss giving her Long Island iced teas in
a school uniform outside of the club
like 30 years ago or some [ __ ] so anyway
it's just this epic story and I messaged
him on his Facebook fan page and was
like hey man this is cool as [ __ ] I want
to get you on the podcast would you
would you do it and he said yeah so
that's pretty fun that'll be good he was
deejaying for Harvey Nichols last night
livestream like so he's he's pretty he's
huge time so he and quite well that was
interesting if you if you want to go
watch that that's cool um Ben Shapiro's
podcast right now is a godsend because
he does it every day Monday to Friday
one hour and it recaps the last 24 hours
usually it means he's got to really
delve into the depths of news to find
something that's interesting so it's
really dispersed but because there's so
much happening every day at the moment
you get to know where the current death
rates are you get to find out what come
what policies are happening that are
going well and what going badly so he is
producing content now at the cadence
that you want someone should produce
content really because he's trying to
find a synthesized version of like
because the only thing that I've been to
fall into which is Ben Ben's
recommendation if you listening Ben
thank you is world ometer which just has
global graphs trend lines logger
rhythmic scales of things new cases
recoveries and deaths but I still that's
not rework there right as well it's you
know you're driving to work or doing
whatever pencha Pires podcast man every
every morning now part of my morning
routine is listening to that Weiland
book so yeah you get an episode in the
UK you'll be listening on a Tuesday
up until on a Saturday and then I guess
Sunday Monday off because he takes the
weekend off but he's brilliant like he's
absolutely amazing the only thing I
would say is if you are listening every
time that he goes we'll come back to
that in just one second immediately say
hey Siri skip forward 90 seconds because
that's the beginning is that work with
Siri yeah Wow yeah that's why you need
that pods man was cool that being
consuming that's been cool I mean I
would really read in super super
impressed by Ben Shapiro's podcast Tiger
king was awesome the Vietnam War
documentary by Ken Burns [ __ ] sick
the UK and US office have both just been
put on I think Netflix or maybe they've
been extra episodes added summer
housemates have been watching that I
really like the US office it's better
than the UK one I think ins yeah I did
yeah
it's um Steve Carell yeah thought of it
like he can do no wrong like I just
really enjoy how he like muddles his way
through and ends up doing quite well
really funny good
I watched something last night called
Official Secrets a film with Becca all
right it's about like the theory that
evidence was doctored to start the Iraq
war
it's not Kira night is it oh it's
dramatized oh I've seen that it's
British thing right and she goes to that
lady's cottage and is like oh will you
leak this thing for me yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
so my brother sent me a whatsapp voice
message it was 30 minutes long it wasn't
him it was like a forward from something
and it was like listen brothers and
sisters in faith this is really
important scientifically logically
and practically because what is
happening here is a huge cover-up and
you need to know this as people of faith
we need to raise our vibrations because
the setting up of 5g is what is :
causing the coronavirus there is no such
thing as contagion there is no such
thing as virus when the 5g comes on it
releases toxin in out of your cells and
it has to come out of your mouth and
nobody has ever proven that a virus can
be contagious we even took the the
sputum the phlegm out of someone with
flu injected it into someone else and we
could not reproduce it is 5g it is
causing ourselves to it and it's like is
to make the people more obedient and you
just so like I started playing it in the
doctor's office and everyone was just
like keep that on just slowly riling
everyone up and getting them really
really angry I've seen quite a bit I've
been sending it to you surf like there's
a few guys that we vaguely follow who
are coaches but have a certain set of
beliefs that aren't necessarily very
evidence-based they say yeah yeah yeah
so he yeah he's B's been saying like
this is all just it's 5g and like we saw
the same guy say if you if you like get
ill don't go to hospital like go into
the forest and let nature heal you know
uh sort of stuff like I I'm all up for
everyone having an opinion and until
it's dangerous and then I think it
should just should just be regulation
just yeah I mean the luckily then and
the minute I think what's happening is
that unnecessary admissions are likely
to drop in hospitals because current now
the risk of being in hospital is much
worse than the risk of being out of
hospital and so if there's something
like and I think this is gonna be a huge
shift for healthcare as a whole in six
months time because now that we've got
the infrastructure that has never really
been used as its capacity is that
there's going to be a shift towards
online consultations and away from a lot
of stuff that doesn't need to be done in
person and I think this is probably the
catalyst for that where they're starting
to realize that so many things so many
like inefficiencies that were previously
just let to carry on now where they're
like oh actually we're forced to really
keep people out of hospital at any cost
it's gonna cause this huge cultural
shift like not only with health care but
with attitudes towards that you know
that obviously the even just socially
people are gonna come out and realize
what they've what they've been missing
they're just the the social interactions
that they've been having and the other
companies is it likely how having that
resisted in my tea
sorry oh yeah it massively ended up what
was it Navarre rava Kant was talking
about I think it was him talking about
maybe 20% of the workforce I can't
remember if we said this on the last one
he said like about 20% of the workforce
have just like silently been able to
just get grandfathered into whatever
they're doing in the company and they're
just in the corners of the offices and
they don't really do anything but no
one's ever kind of questioned it and
actually if they were to just be
eliminated from the workforce nothing
would change
I couldn't agree more there's there's so
much fat in companies and especially
when you look at big bureaucratic
organizations probably in knowledge work
not so much in OP ops and logistics and
like real [ __ ] the number of leaders
area managers office managers you know
like all of that sort of stuff the
people who aren't either making the main
decisions at the top or nose to the
grindstone at the bottom all of those
ones are good they should really be
worried and rightly so if you're a
business who can rip out 20% of your
costs during this period and really
looks I spoke to Mike winner Mike all
right guys it's Mike entrepreneur spoke
to Mike winning he was imagine this
sorry Mike was on holiday in the Canary
Islands with his friends when the
lockdown occurred
[Music]
Oh God he was locked in a hotel the
Canary Islands because it's tax haven or
just for oh so it was holiday like
Easter holiday we did something yeah
yeah
so he's locked that anyway came back and
I asked him as I came on like how's
everything going is like I'm forced now
to really look at the processes and the
operations within my business and refine
them down to their component part had
this guy called Mike McCalla whit's on
last night as well wrote a book called
fix this next so she's just come out and
it's what he's talking about is
absolutely perfect it's like if you
don't have a procedure that is how to be
Jonathan Watson doc in your business so
that you could and you guys have been
saying this for years the e-myth thing I
think that you always quote where it's
like if you can't exit the business and
the business run without you because
there's processes and procedures and
order in place like there's a big hole
that's missing all that well it's just
that you've created a job it's not
created a business yeah so yeah I mean
that's that's it's going to be
interesting to see sort of where
businesses go so I wanted SUNY Webster
asked me this on a IG live the other day
and I thought it was a really cool
question so let's do a little roundtable
of two things that we've been extra
grateful for that we're grateful for
during this period and one thing that we
miss the most Johnny
one thing I miss the most is just seeing
people I think like spending time in
person with like friends and family two
things I'm grateful for it's probably
quits quite a long list to be honest
like grateful I don't have coronavirus
grateful my like none of my immediate
family do more friends but like in terms
of probably what you're asking the
question for I think we've been really
grateful for the way our business is set
up like it's not we're not we don't have
like debt we don't have really high
costs it's all pretty easy to pivot and
adapt and it feels very much like the as
Yusef says it said at the start like the
risks that we took several years ago you
know kind of like the tables have turned
a little bit and actually what we're
doing is now pretty stable compared to
some industries which feels like yeah
you know the safe the safe and sale
people now somehow like the people I was
hearing that like dentists a like in
quite high-risk job now and you when
when in history has dentistry ever been
considered to be like not stable it's
bizarre but now that isn't running a
fitness business on the Internet's like
people right yeah you know it's just
like it's weird so that and then I think
just I think hugely coincidentally for
me the start of this year was like right
when I'm really like we spoke about this
in the in the podcast I mean really like
buckle down on like my morning routine
every day wake up at the same time every
day like doing stuff like cold showers
and wim HOF like stuff to make me feel
good I feel like that I was doing it for
like 90 days almost and then it was like
lockdown and you're like I actually feel
like I feel like mentally in like a
better place and I have been previously
more more consistent and stuff so
grateful that I'd been doing that up to
now so for HIV as well isn't it yeah I'm
so happy I'm so happy with watching I'm
happy and jealous in equal measure
watching the progress you've made over
the last 90 days especially as someone
for whom I wouldn't have presumed
there was a lot of low-hanging fruit
left it's not like this is your first
foray into personal development and
you're like oh well I started sleeping
with me for an outside of me bedroom and
I was like and then I turned the speed
up on my trackpad and I were called
Alfred and like yeah to see someone who
you already presume is somewhere close
to the top of their game make an
outwardly noticeable like upgrade is
pretty legit so I'm super happy for you
man I think that's [ __ ] that is cool
really really cool yes of course I've
got lots of many things the the thing I
miss the most is being at home like just
being able to spend time at home which
is ironic because I think I'm just
jealous of everyone who is able to be at
home and self-isolation
has so much opportunity to do loads with
it but as you said Chris like the
challenge then is being able to
capitalize on that when you're not used
to it and having to actually you've got
so many hours of the day to then be able
to do something with it many things that
I'm looking forward to and grateful for
so cashless payments as Johnny said like
it's well overdue I can't wait for the
Apple card this is an order of
increasing importance so capacity for
medical equipment so ventilators and the
having like motor companies being able
to create ventilators like independent
open sourcing of 3d printing for for
making making extra tubes and valves and
it's like that is fantastic in it it's
all this capacity that we already had
but just being able to then say like
people with 3d printers at home and not
doing bottle with it and suddenly
they're like alright here's what we can
actually put this effort into grateful
for family especially older relatives
and just thinking I actually have taken
these people for granted but something
like this you know there's a when
someone has limited health reserved like
a small knock can completely can
completely throw them off the off
balance as well as my own health and you
know all of our all of our health is
still not something
that's guaranteed and I think even
though we're we're young it's it made
everyone rethink their mortality a
little bit and think actually like young
people can die from this as well and so
access to health care and the fact that
we can you know maintaining our own
health is within our hands is great so
maybe that's maybe I was a bit cynical
about people that are like going out for
jogs just because they've been told not
to like perhaps it is that they were
also motivated by and like oh no I need
to get into shape and you know I need to
go outdoors and so thus not certainly
those are some things I'm grateful for
something I'm less grateful for is well
go ahead just it's just related to that
what's the guy called who's a
competitive eater whose name's Pete
furious Pete yeah so he he got diagnosed
a testicular cancer like I don't know
like it a couple of years ago I think
and I saw a video of him like telling
his followers about it and he's off it's
obviously very emotional but something
that he said and something that I think
I've felt I've realized recently is he
said like when he was diagnosed a lot of
people and they get something like that
like they become more aware of their
mortality obviously that's a lot more
severe than than what we're all going
through but a lot more sudden I should
say so he said like I realized I just
wouldn't do anything differently like I
like my life how it is like I wouldn't a
lot of people have a shock like that and
I'm like right I need to change how I
approach my health and yet changing my
career and all these sorts of things and
he was like no just would be doing
exactly the same thing like wouldn't
change anything is really so nice as a
confirmation if that's how you feel but
also like if you get through this and
you don't have you don't get the virus
or you don't have serious effects from
it all and all your family and your
friends are okay like it's actually a
great thing to have happened to just
remind you like by the way like all the
stuff you kind of take for granted all
the time it's not guaranteed like do you
need a course correction yeah that's
brilliant and to be able to have that
realization to be like you know what
pretty happy with how things have gone
it's amazing my heat things anyone
hasn't seen furious Pete yeah like he
sources a video where he like he drinks
a bottle of olive oil one where he
drinks a
so these are different like macros and
drinks he has a tub of way just like if
it just makes it into a paste and just
pods it in about six minutes there's one
where he drinks a gallon of honey I got
four thousand seven hundred grams of
carbs DP Chris he'd be great to have on
modern wisdom he actually would he's a
lot of fun yeah he's just got some
really he's got some really like strong
aspects to his character
I think he's put himself through a lot
of he's been through a lot of stuff and
it's still just got a great outlook I
don't know that's cool um what was the
letter A Wrinkle for my upstairs
neighbor has taken up the drums my
children sometimes take up the drums and
is having a lot more sex like it is
directly above my bedroom and it's at
all times of the day because no one has
any schedule anymore and the headboard
is said the reason I can differentiate
between drums and sex is that the sex
that doesn't have a defined tempo and
accelerates and have stopped suddenly
and it's against the wall so like as in
there like the headboard banging against
the wall like on one hand I'm like I'm
quite impressed with how much of it like
stallion the boyfriend is because it
goes on for ages and just multiple
multiple times a day at random times but
it's very disruptive especially when you
try to record something and it's a very
difficult problem to have to be like
excuse me I'm trying to record can you
just keep down the everywhere have you
have you signed up to our free webinar
because if you have you'll hear yourself
in the background so can i I want to
just tell let's do a deep dive on this
can we talk about cadence please I mean
we like is he a bit faster okay
I've maintained and you slower than that
but it's it's it's like intermittently
very good place then whereas the drums
you can hit like different kids of the
drums and that's you know yeah okay
what's the what's the average duration
30 to 40 minutes
an average cadence of it does vary say
period dance is a bit and that's
multiple times a day there's like one in
the morning and stuff and you just like
um so here's something for you right and
it's not necessarily related to that but
it's on the same theme I have just
bought the best eye mask I've ever ever
used explain tell us more it's what I
think it's called like Alaska bear I
think it's called it was like 15 quid so
it's it's there's there's um concave
convex concave so there's like circles
that press around your eyes that are
very soft so you can move you're out you
can blink commuter eyes there's nothing
actually pressing your eyes problem I
always have with my with eye masks I
pull them off in the night because it
feels too pressured on my face with
these I don't have that and the the
Rings basically create a as close to a
full suction because they're foam so
they adapt to your the contours of your
face so we have on the other side of our
bedroom a kid who plays video games
until I mean it's not quite the same
like but it's a similar problem it so
I'm like I've been having this thing in
my mind of like I should just get like a
full head sleep kit that came back in
just seven just drop it drop in earplugs
and yeah yeah you see these things that
I like fully wrap around with most
consoling stuff putting in these you get
one that funnily and I just just so you
know the episode which went out on
Monday just gone in podcast land because
this is going to go out on Thursday the
episode which run out on Monday just
gone is Ben Greenfield talking about his
entire daily routine from waking until
sleeping at night including every
product he uses all of the different
sleep masks what he he does a [ __ ]
oil pull in his mouth after he uses a
cop
scraper and it's a combination of talked
about this mate is must be a hundred
plus things that he drops but he's got
the brand of I'm ASCII uses the brand of
red blue blocking glasses that he's
everything everything full works and
I've listened to use on the woot podcast
I think so I've lit I've listened to him
talk about it and he just mentions these
things like and then I go in this room
and I use this like a chilly wave and
then I used their like the Z mask and
then these things and I'm like looking
all these up I was like that's five
grand
that's ten grand that's 1,500 quid in
use like that see I mean I'm sure he
gets it for some kind of sponsorship
deal and he told me about so I I thought
that we were pretty levelled up by
having sunrise alarm clocks and by being
woken up by light like ah those those
[ __ ] prehistoric plebs
yeah those the the proletariat down
there getting woken up by sound like it
to the 1900s [ __ ] them Ben Greenfield
sleeps on a chilly mat and I didn't
realize that the chilly mat has a
function where it can heat up at a time
or cool down at a time so you can be
woken up by heat or cold holy [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you anyone can do that right now like
just thermostat heater on a timer for
the morning and full blasting the main 6
a.m. I think the main reason that he has
it that way is because he sleeps on one
side and his missus sleeps on the other
I think what differential oh they've got
different settings yeah which is just
why is there not an eye mask with lights
in it there is
oh that oh sorry but it's not designed
to wake you up it's designed to induce
lucid dreaming so it detect when you're
in REM sleep and it starts flashing in a
certain pattern designed to somehow
design to keep you asleep but like
trigger that you are dreaming and then
that's lucid dream that's funny so I'll
do um I'll do a couple of the things
that I've been grateful for and some
stuff that I miss definitely grateful
for mom and dad's health like that's
just you know you totally do
I'm also grateful that they have each
other and have the dogs because again
hearing about possibly
hearing about older but people like
people's parents people's grandparents
living on their own at the moment
fearing for your health I keep must be
just so challenging so yes super super
grateful for that for me as well like
the trading circle thing that I have
been a part of for the last few months I
got added to this manage trading account
and the returns that they've seen
especially recently have been fantastic
so the fact that I have a source of
income coming through that which is very
antifragile given the current situation
that's been literally can't believe like
the returns on that which is great and
also the opportunity to do these
podcasts like that you know I'm doing
next week I've got six episodes booked
in and it doesn't feel the bonus because
like that's what my day now is you know
that's my work bit of the day and then
all the other stuff and thing I miss you
too missing you to miss going out for
like sauna chicken coop like getting to
to have you you wondered what's
happening to the sauna like do you
reckon the owner is just using as his
private sauna or is it just molding not
just adjustment pool would you go
somewhere else now yeah a lot of energy
yeah custom I have it turned off yeah if
they keep it on that's all terrible
almost certainly yeah yeah that's gonna
stink when they come back in well I have
a client who's a he's a baguette PT
Elijah centre and he was saying that
they there's like a concern of like
maintaining the pool and stuff like that
because obviously just a big vat of like
chlorine water that all the time has
circulation keep it's running like I
don't know how you then like when you
come back do you need to like fully
drain it and then refill everything I
think just pull the plug at the
beginning a regular them it can ya drink
imagine if you had a little tennis court
you get opened up back into the real
world
after three weeks and you've got to find
whatever like three million cubic feet
of water you liters of water or whatever
the [ __ ] it is like what it's like the
right level of chlorine in the right
temperature you know it's not assuming
pools not just like from the
it's just leave the time leave the tap
running overnight and have a pit
fighting in the morning well I thought
like you could if you just get a bucket
and no two blokes just going back and
forth fill up and over the top or in
yeah okay yeah yeah look gents thank you
so much for coming on propane fitness
calm / modern wisdom for those online
fitness professionals and people who
think that they want to start making it
pivot what else should they where else
should they check out so we never even
plug your stuff we never even say that
well should we just presume that they
already follow you well I saw that I
mean if they're not and what you doing
but we have two main audience is so that
for the business stuff anyone wanting to
do that for its proven fitness calm
forward-slash modern wisdom remember
it's propane as in the gas not stance on
pain and throw fit pain we are not
getting that question console auntie hey
yeah yeah and for the fitness crowd who
just want to get in better shape
especially during this period go to
propane fitness calm forward-slash
calculator or dress protein fitness calm
we also have a free self-isolation
bodyweight program which we're just were
just given away for free no strings
attached just to help you guys out
during this time and crucially we're not
pivoting our entire marketing around
bodyweight programs or live videos I
love it look boys thank you so much I am
I think we should try and we've done
this this was two weeks ago that we did
the last one if we can get another one
in in a weekend coming up soon you are
by far the most requested of all guests
which is ridiculously I can try and book
on Ben Greenfield or or Bray Marcus
enough you got that Arab and the read
the one with the really long legs again
Captain Hook and and that's the Aryan
one yeah yeah it doesn't look like as
much of a giant neither the perspectives
normal no
you've been noting a knitting harem too
though well normally I'm start like next
to the camera on a fisheye lens just
excellent color tonight before we finish
off this is a public service
announcement to everyone else that's
suffering with the same thing I am I
cannot stop eating I can't stop eating
at the moment because I'm never leaving
the house I'm constantly near the
kitchen and I'm training a fair bit so
today today I clocked in at the heaviest
I've ever weighed 90.2 kilos so what
you're experiencing now Chris this is
this weird thing that that a lot of
people have to go through which is being
careful in and tracking what they
consume on track in order to be obscene
tracking because you still just
MyFitnessPal at the moment is 200 to 60
60 and I'm hitting it within like 20 so
it's like 2 to 4.5 that fat carbs and
protein I'd be an interesting day Oh God
very loose day yeah so what you aren't
you are tracking it so yeah to be honest
i it's not that's not really change for
me
you're very again with I don't I am like
I struggle with I get really hungry like
I'm quite a big person I move around
quite a bit I train so and then like not
eating very much foods quite difficult
but yeah what do you what do you eat
talk us through a day of eating in the
life of Chris fastest or fastest or
fasted until mmm about 1 or 2 p.m. some
training at midday every day with my
flatmate at the moment Lois which is
good super super fortunate aleyko anyone
who actually needs me forgot
anyone who still needs kit like
dumbbells kettlebells weights plates
bars stuff like that aleyko because
they're Swedish and they've basically
they're just going about their daily
business as is normal they're still
delivering everything so just had to I
think it's like a lake or codit you care
just Google L e ee l e i KO e le i KO
machine there
April Fool's thing no it was it
oh man that their April Fool's things
are the best of any company so it's a
portable barbell in a box we go just go
on their Instagram have a look at it and
then scroll back on all the previous
like they did a waffle iron they they
did square plates and it's really highly
I produce the eerie look [ __ ] likes per
square plates is that better
should I be things so yeah if you need
if you need kit final thing here's my
final thing for everyone hold on you
didn't your day of eating so fasted
until 2 p.m. post training then shake
and bananas some sort of fruit like
shake jump up and down wriggle myself
around so that is bulk powders beef
isolate then my days cooking's already
been done that's part of my morning
routine and that will be three chicken
breasts and 260 grams of rice with
vegetables salad and some sort of source
and that's just split into my Tupperware
for the day so I eat those as the day
goes on probably one bear bells or one
sort of protein works crunky type snack
thing to keep me going and then an
evening time is granola with vanilla
bear bells milkshake and that comes out
at pretty much bang on getting the
protein in it's a challenge like 200
grams of protein a day is it doesn't
sound like much but actually it's quite
sort of challenging without isn't it
like it's it easy when you have eat lean
cheese when you basically get when your
cheese is essentially a protein
supplement it's a cheese is nice
obviously cheese is good here's my final
thing Bob Mortimer on instagram have
either have you seen him you know Bob
Mortimer is a British comedian older
fella does Mortimer are you both
recognize who he has been in tons and
tons and tons of stuff he's created a
character who only exists on it on his
Instagram and it's called train guy and
he must have just heard this like
British entrepreneur on the train
talking about all of the different
things that he does so he's now all that
his Instagram is is him doing these
pretend phone calls to people to face
just like this like not produced at all
I'd promise you it's one of the best
series that I've ever seen it wouldn't
surprise me if it becomes like a proper
TV show and it's just [ __ ] phenomenal
so I'm gonna leave you if you haven't
seen that already there's a rabbit hole
of probably 30 or 40 posts yeah yeah 30
or 40 posts and then there's this other
guy called Jeff lint and the lint inator
and he comes on sometimes and talks
about it but look
propene fitness comm slash monomers do
more protein fitness comm slash
calculator if you are interested in
looking at pivoting online or getting
some free workouts to do at home no more
jumping squats and if you've enjoyed the
episode give me a message and I can
screenshot it to the boys and make them
come back on because the reason they did
is because I got hassled so much like
share and subscribe you already know
what to do
gentlemen we did it thank you wonderful
[Music]
you